PRESIDENT.
THIS IS CRAZY LAND.
THE PEOPLE ARE ON TO THIS.
GREAT TO SEE YOU BOTH.
FOX NEWS ALERT, MOMENTS AGO,
FANTASTIC NEWS, 9-YEAR-OLD
CHARLOTTE SENA WHO VANISHED
WHILE CAMPING WITH HER FAMILY IN
UPSTATE, NEW YORK HAS BEEN FOUND
ALIVE.
FOX NEWS MOLLY LINE IS LIVE FROM
WILTON, NEW YORK WITH ALL THE
DETAILS, MOLLIE?
>> LAURA, JUST THE BEST POSSIBLE
NEWS AT THIS POINT IN TIME 48
HOURS INTO THE INVESTIGATION, WE
ARE GETTING WORD FROM THE NEW
YORK STATE POLICE THAT CHARLOTTE
SENA HAS BEEN LOCATED AND IS IN
GOOD HEALTH.
A SUSPECT IS IN CUSTODY.
THEY SAY THIS IS STILL AN ACTIVE
INVESTIGATION.
THEY WILL BE RELEASING MORE
DETAILS WHEN THEY COME.
I ALSO HAVE WORD THAT HER FAMILY
IS ON THE WAY TO REUNITE WITH
CHARLOTTE.
SO TREMENDOUS, ENORMOUS GOOD
NEWS AT THIS POINT IN THE
INVESTIGATION WHEN SOMETIMES
THINGS CAN LOOK VERY GRIM.
HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE
HAVE POURED OUT EVERYTHING THEY
HAVE.
HAVE HIT THE GROUND HERE IN THIS
AREA OF UPSTATE, NEW YORK TO
SEARCH SWAMPS AND WATERWAYS.
SOME 400 SEARCH AND RESCUE
PERSONNEL.
THE NEW YORK STATE POLICE, FBI,
MOUNTAIN RESCUE TEAMS.
ALL OUT THERE IN THE FORESTS
HAVE BEEN LOOKING FOR HER SINCE
SATURDAY EVENING WHEN SHE HAD
GONE OUT ON THIS BIKE RIDE AT
6:15 P.M. WITH FRIENDS WITH
CHILDREN THAT SHE KNEW.
SHE.
ED TO TAKE ONE MORE LOOP AROUND
THIS CAMPGROUND THAT SHE WAS
STAYING AT IN THE MOROSE STATE
PARK HERE IN THIS AREA OF NEW
YORK WHEN SHE DISAPPEARED WITHIN
15 MINUTES HER FAMILY WAS
LOOKING FOR HER.
15 MINUTES LATER THEY FIND THAT
BICYCLE.
HER MOTHER CALLS 911.
AND IN THE BEST POSSIBLE
OUTCOME, CHARLOTTE IS FOUND
ALIVE.
A TREMENDOUS OUTCOME AT THIS
POINT IN TIME.
THE GOVERNOR WAS UP HERE GIVING
A PRESS CONFERENCE YESTERDAY.
STATE POLICE.
THEY TALKED ABOUT ALL OF THE
ASSETS THAT WERE BEING POURED IN
AND WE HAVE WATCHED THEM ARRIVE
THROUGHOUT THE DAY AND DISPERSE
BUS LOADS AND BUS LOADS OF
PEOPLE.
34 DIFFERENT VOLUNTEER FIRE
AGENCIES INVOLVED IN GOING
THROUGH THIS REALLY THICK BRUSH
AND WOOD AND WATER LANDS AND ONE
OF THE THINGS THE GOVERNOR SAID
IN THE PRESS CONFERENCE
YESTERDAY, SHE TALKED WITH THE
COMMUNICATIONS THEY WERE
ANALYZING.
IN THAT TIME, AROUND THE
DISAPPEARANCE AND THE VERY
BEGINNING OF THIS INVESTIGATION
WE KNOW THOSE FIRST MINUTES AND
HOURS CAN BE SO CRITICAL.
AND WE DON'T KNOW SPECIFICALLY,
WHAT LED INVESTIGATORS TO THIS
SUSPECT OR WHAT THE SPECIFIC
CHARGES WILL BE.
WE'RE WAITING TO HEAR THAT.
BUT THE BEST POSSIBLE OUTCOME AT
THIS POINT IN TIME THAT
CHARLOTTE SENA HAS BEEN FOUND
ALIVE.
THE AMBER ALERT HAS BEEN
CANCELED.
LAURA?
>> Laura: EVERY PARENT ACROSS
THE COUNTRY, EVERY AMERICAN,
EVERY MOM HEARS TH